en este vídeo analizaremos por qué pedir
en las restas funciona y esto tiene un
sentido ya veremos haremos el primer
ejercicio y nos preguntamos cuánto será
mil 5
- 616
la manera en la que nosotros vamos a
dividir esto va a ser colocar estos
mismos números de la siguiente manera
recuerdan que siempre los dividimos por
columnas esto significa que tenemos
unidades de millar
de millar centenas
decenas
y unidades
qué quiere decir esto que es de mil
cinco lo que significa es que hay una
unidad de millar
hay 0 centenas 0 decenas y 5 unidades o
lo que es lo mismo 1000 más 5 ok ahora
nos vamos con el siguiente 616 esto
significa que hay 6 centenas o 600 más
una decena o 10 más 6 unidades
616 es igual a 610 más 6 cómo funciona
esto de pedir si vemos esta operación
tenemos que es pequeño el 5 y eso nos
causa un problema ya que necesitamos que
este se convierta en 15 podemos pedir de
las decenas no no realmente podemos
pedir de las centenas no tampoco pero sí
podemos pedir de la unidad de millar lo
que queremos es volver a desmenuzar esto
tenemos que vamos a pedirle a esta
unidad de millar correcto
esta unidad del millar la vamos a
digamos que deshacer lo que haremos es
aquí necesitamos un 15 por lo tanto hay
que pedir 10 tenemos los 10
que estamos pidiendo más el 5 original
porque esto será nuestra unidad
para que lleguemos a las 1000 estaremos
hablando que nos quedan 99 decenas y
novecientos y nueve centenas esta unidad
de millar la deshicimos la tachamos 900
más 90 más 10 son 1000 se dan cuenta
como aquí está dividido esto
esa unidad de millares está aquí 1000
está dividido entre 990 más 10 y este 5
corresponde al 5 original
si bajamos el número al que vamos a
restar tenemos 610 más safe ahora si
podemos hacer nuestra división vámonos
número por número 15 menos 6 es igual a
9 90 menos 10 es igual a 80
novecientos menos 600 es igual a 300
por lo tanto 300 más 89 es igual a 389
tiene más sentido y si lo hacemos de la
otra manera como lo habíamos manejado
veremos que si aquí pedimos 1 será 15
menos 69
este que pedimos prestado lo vamos a
pagar aquí
y este se vuelve un 2 este 0 es más
pequeño que 2 por lo tanto pediremos
prestado
110 - 2 es igual a 8 este uno que
pedimos prestado lo vamos a pagar aquí
7 y 7 es más grande que el 0 volvemos a
pedir prestado aquí
10 menos 7 es igual a 3
este uno que pedimos prestado lo vamos a
pagar aquí por lo que uno menos uno es
igual a cero y volvemos a tener 389 como
lo tuvimos aquí
vamos a hacer un ejemplo más para que
esto sea mucho más claro hagamos espacio
qué pasa si ahora tenemos 995 menos
616 vamos a volver a dividirlo como lo
hicimos hace un momento en centenas
decenas y unidades 995 va a ser igual a
900 más 90 más 5
y 616 será igual a 600
10 + 6 ven como lo hemos dividido una
vez más ahora lo que haremos es buscar
columna por columna o categoría por
categoría la posibilidad de hacer la
resta aquí tenemos que 5 es menor que 6
por lo tanto requeriremos pedirle a las
decenas para que éste se vuelva un 15 lo
que haremos es cambiar este 90 y será 80
más
estamos de acuerdo y aquí ponemos
nuestro 900 así nos funcionará
pongamos ahora nuestra segunda cifra que
600 más 10 más 6
15 ahora es más grande que 6 y nos podrá
funcionar la resta 80 es más grande que
10 entonces aún estamos bien y podemos
hacer nuestra resta también y 900
también es más grande que 600 por lo
tanto creo que estamos listos para hacer
nuestra resta veamos cuánto es 15 menos
6 esto es igual a 980 menos 10 es igual
a 70 900 menos 600 es igual a 300
por lo tanto 379 es igual a 379
en caso de que tengan un examen o algo
así en el que ocupen hacer esta
operación rapidísimo vamos a volverlo a
hacer de esta manera lo que estoy
buscando aquí es que ustedes puedan
identificar cómo funciona el por qué
funciona y eso es importantísimo sumamos
10 y este 15 menos 6 es igual a 9 este 1
que tomamos prestado lo vamos a pagar
aquí uno más uno es igual a 2
9 - 2 es igual a 7
y en este caso no pedimos prestado nada
se queda nuestro 6 igual 9 menos seis es
igual a 3
379 de la misma manera que tuvimos aquí
vamos bien que tal hacer un ejercicio
más
para el otro lado y aquí haremos la
siguiente resta cuántos serán cuánto
será 732 menos 23 esto está mucho más
sencilla
vamos a hacerlo rápidamente como ustedes
ya están aprendiendo centenas decenas
unidades
tenemos que 732 es igual a 7 centenas o
700 tres decenas
32 unidades es decir 7 billetes de 100 3
monedas de 10 y 2 monedas de peso de la
misma manera el 23 es igual a dos
monedas de 10 o 20 más 3
hagamos columna por columna podemos aquí
al 2 restarle 3 no necesitaremos
entonces convertir este 30 en 20
tachamos este 30 y lo convertimos en un
2020 más los 10 que le estoy prestando
más los dos originales son 12 y este 700
lo bajamos de la misma manera como
estaba 3
+ 20 es igual a 23 que es este 23 ya
tenemos números a los cuales podemos
restarle entonces 12 menos 3 es igual a
9 20 menos 20 es igual a 0 700 0 es
igual a 700 700 más 0 decenas más 9 es
igual a 709 hagámoslo tipo examen ahí
eso suena muy peligroso lo único que
quiero es que lo vean más rápido este 3
es más grande que este 2 ocuparemos
prestarle 112 menos 3 es igual a 9 este
uno que pedimos prestado lo pagamos aquí
más uno más dos son igual a tres
3 - 3 - 3 es igual a 0 y aquí ya no
pedimos prestado absolutamente nada por
lo que este 7 bajará directamente
y tenemos una vez más los mismos 709 que
tenemos acá ojo ustedes no requieren
hacerlo así todo el tiempo vaya esta es
una forma en la que ustedes pueden
comprobar que esté funcionando
lo importante es que entiendan el por
qué funciona y esto es básico porque
mucha gente aprende a hacer las cosas
por regla y de repente se les olvidan
las reglas y ya no se acuerdan cómo se
hace
sin embargo cuando ustedes entienden y
razonan de dónde viene todo esto va a
tener sentido en su cabeza y esto nos va
a ayudar a que jamás se nos olvide
hagamos uno más cuánto será 512 menos 38
rápidamente volvemos a separar por
categorías en centenas decenas y
unidades que corresponde a las tres
columnas que estamos viendo en este
punto 512 es igual a 500 más 10
cinco billetes de cien una moneda de
diez y dos monedas de dos pesos
le pondré este menos porque corresponde
la operación y 38 va a ser igual a tres
monedas de 10
+ 8 monedas de pesos y 8 unidades
y veamos dos es más chico que el 8 por
lo que vamos a ocupar pedirle a este 10
y si este 10 lo convertimos en 0 porque
lo estamos pidiendo tenemos que 500 +0 +
12 que aquí ya lo movimos es la misma
manera en la que se conforma este número
y también haremos lo correspondiente con
el 38 30 más
8 y con esto tenemos que ahora ya
podemos hacer esta primer resta sin
embargo aquí tenemos un punto importante
pero no es más grande que 30 por lo que
hemos de pedirle prestado a este 500 lo
convertiremos ahora en 400
y aquí tendremos 100 vamos a hacerlo
aquí abajo 400 más
+ 12 es igual a 512
bajemos esto un poco
y el 30 quedará como 30 más
volvamos a analizar
esta columna ya la podemos restar esta
columna ya la podemos restar y esta
columna no tiene nada más que restar por
lo que hagamos las operaciones 12 menos
8 es igual a 4
100 - 30 es igual a 70 y este 400 como
esta sin restar se le nada o podemos
ponerle un 0 es igual a 400
por lo tanto 518 menos 38 es igual a 474
veámoslo en forma examen
me gusta decir eso dejémoslo en forma
examen
este 8 es más grande que el 2 por lo
tanto pediremos prestado 112 - 8 es
igual a 4 este 1 que pedimos prestado
aquí lo vamos a pagar abajo 13 es igual
a 4
este uno de arriba nos resulta más
pequeño que este 4 que acabamos de sumar
pediremos prestado 111 menos 4 es igual
a 7
y de la misma manera todo lo que pedimos
prestado hay que pagarlo este uno que
pedimos prestado lo vamos a pagar aquí
cinco menos uno es igual a cuatro
llegamos exactamente a los 474 que hemos
visto aquí abajo
ahora saben por qué funciona esto de
prestar durante las restas espero que
poco a poco vayan teniendo una mejor
idea de ello y podamos lograr restar con
una facilidad mucho mayor nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo